في ذروه المعارك المحتدمه في ضخمه
الاوكرانيه خطر اساسي يهدد التقدم الروسي
وهو خلافات الصف الواحد بين مجموعه التي
تقاتل في المدينه والكرملين
قد تكون فاكنير التالي لموسكو هذا ما ذهب
اليه معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي الذي يرى
ان الدفاع الروسيه تعطي الاولويه حاليا
للقضاء على قوات فاجنر في بخمه بعد الهجوم
الحاد من قبل بريجوجين على وزير الدفاع
السيرجيو ورئيس الاركان العامه
هناك مواجهه مباشره لا تقل عن كونها
محاوله لتدمير فادنر وترقى الى خيانه
للوطن في حين تقاتل فاجنر من اجل باخموت
وتتكبد خسائر بشريه بالمئات كل يوم
الش
قاق حد وصل لدرجه قطع وزاره الدفاع
الذخيره عن فاجنر بعد ان استنفذت كامله
دخيلتها في المعارك وطلبت موسكو
بالامدادات الغريب ان الدفاع الروسيه قطعت
طرق التواصل مع فاجنر رغم ان الاخيره
تحققت تقدما لافتا شرقيه اوكرانيا وضمنت
لموسكو السيطره على المزيد من الاراضي
بعض المحللين يرون ان موسكو تتارجح بين
رغبتين الاولى هي انتزاع بخموت كنصر
استراتيجي يمهد الطريق نحو غربي اوكرانيا
والثانيه هي التغلب على مخاوف بوتين من
طموحات بريكوجين التوسعيه ومؤخرا كانت
تقارير غربيه تنبات بطموح بريروجين لتحويل
فاجنر الى منظومه عسكريه موازيه تحمل
الطابع عن ايديولوجيا ويكون لها دورها
المنفصل عن الكرملين في اوكرانيا اذا عمر
العربيه